hoje é um dia muito especial pra mim é
muito especial especial por poder estar
aqui compartilhando com vocês idéias
sobre educação uma das minhas grandes
paixões especial porque há exatamente 15
anos nascia a júlia a minha filha e
júlia assim como tantos outros
adolescentes inspiram a sonhar e buscar
uma educação diferente uma educação mais
criativa
eu costumo dizer que eu sou uma
professora viajante
além de annaba viajar
uma outra paixão conhecer lugares
conhecer pessoas
eu sempre busquei caminhos diferentes
para uma educação que pudesse
transformar as pessoas a uma educação
que fizesse sentido uma educação que
tornasse os nossos meninos e meninas
autores da sua jornada
eu convido vocês agora a viajar comigo
topo
ai que bom durante todos esses anos são
mais de 30 anos com a professora fiz
muitas viagens viagens por textos livros
e idéias filosofias me aventurei por
vezes em terras desconhecidas para
encontrar outras formas de fazer
educação formas que ultrapassassem
aquela educação bancária é que considera
que o aluno não sabe nada e o professor
é o detentor do saber e portanto
deposita o conhecimento não
definitivamente não era essa a educação
que eu queria mas então o que significa
essa educação criativa bem a gente
pensar em educação criativa é
interessante pensar em aprendizagem
criativa o nicho resnick pesquisador do
enai time
leve ele nos propõe uma reflexão muito
interessante para pensarmos em
aprendizagem criativa ou seja observarão
com as crianças pequenas do
jardim-de-infância aprendem observem
elas aprendem experimentando elas
aprendem criando colaborando
elas aprendem brincando
elas aprendem sem medo de errar portanto
elas aprendem de forma criativa a medida
em que as crianças crescem e se inserem
no ensino fundamental a escola se torna
muito mais quadrada muito mais formatada
muito mais cheias de muros e muito menos
criativa
o grupo de pesquisa life lonking negar
ter que significa jardim de infância
para toda a vida coordenada pelo mit ou
light mídia é pro punho que o estilo de
aprendizagem dos jardins de infância
possa estar presente durante toda a vida
que todos possam aprender desenvolvendo
projetos através dos seus interesses das
suas paixões com seus pares colaborando
socializando que possam aprender
brincando
são os quatro peso da aprendizagem
criativa no brasil nós temos uma rede
brasileira de aprendizagem criativa que
discute e apoia a aprendizagem criativa
em todo o país
mas vocês devem estar se perguntando que
aprendizagem criativo tem a ver com o
fazer pedagógico de almara bem
há cerca de três anos eu me inseri e
integrei ao grupo de professores do
centro juvenil de ciência e cultura o
centro juvenil de ciência e cultura é
uma escola pública
da rede estadual de ensino que oferece a
alunos do final do ensino fundamental e
do ensino médio cursos atividades
oficinas né pra escolas da região é o
centro juvenil é um laboratório de
inovação pedagógica atualmente nós temos
nove centros juvenis na bahia quatro
deles recém inaugurados o centro juvenil
de vitória da conquista iniciou a sua
caminhada em 2016
lugo que eu conheci o centro juvenil eu
percebi que aquela era uma escola
diferente e que a lei eu poderia
vivenciar a aprendizagem criativa
o centro juvenil não tem os alunos eles
não são divididos por faixa etária ou
por série mas por interesses em comum
nós temos na mesma turma alunos de
diferentes idades diferentes séries e de
diferentes escolas contemplando uma
diversidade riquíssima no centro juvenil
a gente não tem cadeiras enfileiradas o
espaço ele é pensado para desenvolver a
criatividade para que os alunos possam
desenvolver os seus projectos serem
autores daquilo que eles quiserem ser os
alunos
lá são autores da sua jornada eles
escolhem está no centro juvenil eles
escolhem estar na escola eles escolhem o
que eles querem aprender e quando eles
querem aprender
portanto eles se tornam protagonistas do
processo de aprendizagem
a experiência do centro juvenil este ano
me proporcionou me levou ao haiti
nós fomos um dos oito projetos
brasileiros selecionados
a fio de aprendizagem criativa eu eo
coordenador estadual dos centros juvenis
eo rubin
tivemos a oportunidade de ir aos estados
unidos conhecer os projetos
desenvolvidos no enai time de lap que o
laboratório de inovação do e night uma
das maiores e mais conceituadas
universidades do mundo conhecer projetos
educacionais inovadores e mais do que
isso levar e mostrar apresentar para os
pesquisadores daquela instituição os
projetos desenvolvidos por nossos alunos
do centro juvenil foi uma experiência
incrível inesquecível
a equipe do centro juvenil ela é
cotidianamente desafiada a pensar e
entender o que os jovens gostam qual é o
interesse deles o que agencia o desejo
deles pelo saber o que nos interessa é
que a gente possa desenvolver cursos
interdisciplinares que sejam
interessantes que eles queiram
participar no curso aventuras em série
por exemplo trouxe pra vocês verem os
alunos aprendem história filosofia
literatura através de séries como star
wars harry potter
percy jackson no curso um mais um é mais
que 2
os alunos aprendem matemática através da
gastronomia a fotografia na arte da moda
do esporte
e pasmem eles amam matemática no curso
criando games
eles criam seus próprios jogos
desenvolve o pensamento computacional
aprendem lógica de programação e
aprendem muitos conteúdos que imagem
os seus próprios projectos nem aprender
matemática e inglês entre outros
conteúdos aprendem brincando
desenvolvendo seus próprios projetos em
todos os cursos do centro juvenil eu
poderia ficar né o a palestra inteira
que falando dos cursos em todos eles os
alunos aprendem a trabalhar em grupo
eles aprendem a desenvolver o gosto pela
leitura eles aprendem a aprender e além
disso eles têm oportunidade de
participar da incubadora de projetos
a incubadora de projetos é mais um
espaço de produção do conhecimento onde
eles podem criar os seus próprios
projetos e desenvolver produtos
inovadores no ano passado na incubadora
de projetos
tiago filipe luis desenvolveram
utilizando o escrete que é uma
ferramenta é de de programação em blocos
desenvolvido há um ano a emitir pelo
grupo do mitchell
os meninos criar um jogo chamado choices
o choices é um jogo divertido e que
trata da importância da alimentação
saudável e da prática de atividade
física para uma qualidade de vida para
desenvolver esse jogo esses meninos
tiveram que aprender além de lógica de
programação tiveram que estudar sobre
nutrição e índice de massa corporal
pirâmide alimentar entre tantos outros
conteúdos
o chance foi premiado pela fundação de
amparo à pesquisa do estado da bahia e
esses meninos receberam um prémio de
cinco mil reais
eles escreveram um artigo sobre a
experiência do jogo e foram apresentar
esse artigo no congresso da sociedade
brasileira para o progresso da ciência
que no ano passado aconteceu em belo
horizonte
então esses meninos tiveram muito muito
sucesso com essa produção autoral deles
como orientadora
o projeto eu tive a oportunidade de
receber o prêmio professores do brasil
na etapa estadual
o shoe sis hoje é um dos 30 projetos que
compõem o banco de práticas inspiradoras
do ministério da educação
esse projeto tem mudado a vida desses
meninos hoje luís já é aluno da
universidade estadual do sudoeste da
bahia e voluntário na incubadora de
projetos e segue ajudando outros colegas
a desenvolver os seus próprios projetos
renata começou a participar dos cursos
do centro juvenil quando ainda estava no
nono ano
uma menina tímida que foi levada por sua
mãe para fazer o curso para participar
do curso programa aí hoje renata
finalizando o segundo ano do ensino
médio eu posso dizer que é uma
pesquisadora renata já desenvolveu
vários projetos na incubadora do centro
juvenil entre eles um projeto sobre
sustentabilidade
esse projeto levou renata febrace este
ano
a febrace é a maior feira de ciências e
engenharia do brasil organizada pela usp
renata foi para são paulo apresentar o
projeto dela ela também escreveu um
artigo científico e participou este ano
em maceió do congresso da sbpc
participou também da campus party
então são muitas muitos desdobramentos
dos projetos que esses meninos estão
desenvolvendo criando e e autor ando por
causa dos bons resultados desse projeto
que renata fez hoje ela é bolsista
júnior do cnpq e segue desenvolvendo
outros projetos na incubadora
esse ano o centro juvenil participou da
maratona técnica
hoje os móveis na educação que foi uma
realização do unicef e samsung
foram mais de 200 projetos desenvolvidos
e o enviados para a maratona e 32 foram
selecionados para a final o centro
juvenil de vitória da conquista teve
duas equipes entre os 32 finalistas
as únicas finalistas do estado da bahia
felipe márcia puderam desenvolver dois
aplicativos junto com alunos de
graduação da uesb do ifba e da usp eles
no mês passado foram para são paulo para
o evento final onde eles apresentaram o
produto os aplicativos que eles
desenvolveram pra avaliadores da de
várias universidades tiveram
oportunidade também de conhecer várias
empresas grandes empresas de tecnologia
tão filipe márcia receberam junto com o
grupo um prêmio de cada grupo recebeu um
prémio de cinco mil reais e equipamentos
o os aplicativos crítico é che e
cartográfico estão na place tony e eu
convido vocês a fazer o download
divertir-se são aplicativos muito muito
interessantes e vão ser usados detalhe
em todas as escolas públicas do brasil
os 32 aplicativos feitos por essas 32
equipes vão ser inseridos em todas as
escolas públicas através do ministério
da educação
a mais recente conquista do centro
juvenil daqui da nossa cidade foi há uma
semana
nós recebemos o prêmio de educação
criativa inovadora
foram mais de mil projetos de todo o
brasil enviados para participar desse
prêmio e 80 projetos foram selecionados
para a final eu fui pra são paulo muito
feliz por está entre os 80 finalistas
afinal a gente faz uma educação
diferente mas tem muita gente no brasil
que faz uma educação diferente também
para a nossa grande alegria e surpresa o
projeto de produção de jogos como
estratégia para a produção do
conhecimento desenvolvido no centro
juvenil aqui de vitória da conquista foi
o vencedor nacional na categoria ensino
médio eu fiquei muito emocionado em
receber esse esse prêmio não tem um
prêmio em si mas porque isso demonstra
que a gente está no caminho certo de que
é possível fazer uma educação diferente
uma educação mais criativa e isso é
educação criativa uma educação que abre
espaço para o diálogo uma educação em
que o erro faz parte do processo de
aprendizagem uma educação que desenvolve
a criatividade e desenvolve a autonomia
em que os alunos não são meros usuários
nas são autores
uma educação que aproxima a educação
básica da universidade uma educação mais
mão na massa uma educação mais humana
uma educação que da perspectiva de
futuro para esses meninos e meninas e
que pode transformar a vida deles
essa é a educação que eu acredito e
assim como paulo freire eu sei que a
educação não transforma o mundo a
educação muda pessoas e as pessoas
transformam o mundo
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]